we are just six days away from the tax
filing deadline it is Tuesday folks next
week United Way of Southern Nevada
partnering with the IRS and volunteer
income tax assistance programs to make
your filing a little bit easier and for
some of you free Janet Quintero the vice
president of external Affairs joining us
to talk about some of the events that
you guys have planned so first of all
free is a big important thing people
have to do their taxes they don't
necessarily want to pay and then have to
pay more so who can get this of advice
and help for free exactly and that's why
I'm here today so United Way of Southern
Nevada is very happy to partner with the
Nevada Secretary of State's office and
our local Vita science providers to
provide free income tax preparation to
individuals and families making less
than sixty thousand dollars a year okay
so less than 60 you get this service for
free and and where do you go and how do
you find a location to help you out with
these documents absolutely so you can
always call Nevada 2-1-1 if you're not
aware of Nevada 211 it's a great
resource out there that has everything
you can think of resource related so you
call nevada211 you let them know your
zip code and they will share the local
Vita sites closer to your area however I
am here promoting two special events
that we have coming up with the Nevada
Secretary of State's office one of them
is on Friday April 14th from 9 to 2 p.m
and that is at the Manuel Cortes
elementary school and then the other one
is on Saturday April 15th at Chicanos
por la causa or cpoc for short from 10
a.m to 3 P.M okay so Friday and Saturday
this week and and folks like we said the
deadline is Tuesday so you really don't
want to mess around you've got to get
these documents bring in your tax stuff
um if you make over sixty thousand
dollars and you still need assistance
can you guys provide that you can walk
in and you can see if the the volunteer
or the tax experts can help you with
that um however this program is specific
for low and moderate income individuals
those up to 60 000 or less however again
Nevada 211 is just a great resource out
there so if you do need support I
recommend you call them okay and as far
as United Way and the things that you
guys also provide to other individuals
uh what other things do you have going
on right now that might help people as
they get ready for tax season absolutely
well one huge thing is that United Way
We Love Our volunteers so if you want to
volunteer for either this program or
something else we have a lot of great
things coming up go to
volunteer.uwsn.org to learn more about
our programs if you need help or if you
just want to join us and volunteer great
Janet we're going to put all this
information folks on the website so that
you can have quick access to it but 211
such a great resource certainly probably
underutilized too it's always a good
reminder thank you for waking up early
though you can come in on the show free
help for your taxes Friday and Saturday
again it'll be on our website
8newsnow.com